So Donald Trump did something seemingly inconceivable
during a press briefing last week.
He wondered aloud about taking heat light
as well as surface disinfectant, bleach and
isopropyl alcohol and putting them.
Inside the body to fight coronavirus, this
was instantaneously one of the most viral
and sickening moments of Trump's presidency
heard round the world.
I will get to that part later.
But I want to be really clear about this before
we move on.
I tweeted this over the weekend, the scariest
part about the injecting disinfectant fiasco.
Isn't that Trump is so dumb?
He is.
He's clueless about everything, medical.
And many other things.
But the real scary part is that Trump has
been briefed by experts for months about how
viruses work, about social distancing, about
all of this stuff.
But he's still imagining that the solution
could be something like injecting bleach.
Right.
Something could materialize that would make
all of the briefings and expert testimony
moot because, hey, maybe if you put Lysol
in the body, we could take care of this thing.
That's the crisis that he so misunderstands
the problem that something like that would
even conceivably be the solution.
He's sitting around.
After being told about, here's the timeline
for vaccines.
Here's how therapeutics will be tested here.
You know, the ah, not of a virus determines
how quickly it spreads.
And here's how social distancing can affect
that.
We're developing treatments.
We're clearly going to surpass the sixty thousand
a death toll that you've been talking about.
And he's sitting around thinking, you know,
maybe we inject the bleach and that solves
the problem.
That's the scary part in the entire thing
has turned into such a shameful embarrassment
for Trump that he bailed on taking a single
question during Friday's press briefing briefings.
Briefings were immediately announced to be
paired down.
Axios first reported that there's gonna be
a big cutback on briefings.
They will be shorter.
He may not be taking questions.
No briefing on Saturday.
No briefing on Sunday.
Some of Trump's closest advisers have apparently
convinced him that the press briefings are
hurting him more than they are helping him.
He's overexposed.
They're a spectacle and it's really bad.
Which we knew from day one.
The other thing is there is actually not that
much to say each day in the sense that it's
the same lies, he says, where no one in testing.
We're actually forty first in per capita testing.
He says our death rate is super low.
Well, actually, we have the 16th highest death
rate in the world out of more than 180 countries
with the virus.
And that's how you end up rambling and saying
something like, what about putting bleach
in the body?
Now, notably before going into hiding, Trump
did try to argue.
I said it, but it was sarcastic.
Take a look at this.
You're asking a question sarcastically to
reporters like you just to see what would
happen now.
Disinfectant for a this.
Maybe other hands would work.
I was asking the question of the gentleman
who was there yesterday, Bill.
Because when they say that something will
last three or four hours or six hours.
But if the sun is out or if they use disinfectant,
it goes away in less than a minute.
Did you hear about this yesterday?
So before Trump realized that he needs to
stop taking questions or he's going to be
asked about this.
He tried.
It was like a trial balloon.
Tell them it was sarcasm.
Totally nonsensical, first of all.
I don't know that Trump really knows what
sarcasm is versus a joke versus a pun.
But secondly, like, what is the joke?
What's the punchline?
What kind of a sarcastic thing to say is it?
Maybe we inject disinfectants to see how the
media would react react.
So Trump went into hiding over the weekend.
He did not take a break from Twitter, though,
and we're going to talk about that a little
bit later.
Spending the weekend in the context of global
shame and I'll show you examples of that later.
Just rage tweeting about the media.
So the big news is Trump spent the weekend
sheltering in place, so to speak, from the
media.
Even some right wing news outlets like the
website Drudge Report mocked him with images
of bleach to OBL's.
Neil CAVUTO from Fox News made it clear Trump
is lying when he says it was sarcastic.
So this is where we are right now.
And we will see what today's press briefing
looks like.
Let's take a quick break.
Let me know what you expect.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
And we'll be right back with much more.